[Musique]
lorsque vous venez visiter les châteaux
de forbin vous pouvez trouver des
oeuvres de post graffiti et de la scène
de lift ville edge les oeuvres qui ont
été produites dans les années 80 et 90
par des artistes pionniers du graffiti
new-yorkais
[Musique]
là on arrive dans la partie bibliothèque
où on peut voir les photographies
d'henri chalfant et de martha cooper
photographies qui sont des tirages
d'époque on voit vraiment les trains en
situation dans les rues de new york
[Musique]
on dit white est considéré comme léonard
de vinci du graffiti ou le style master
général est ici ce sont donc trois
collage est notamment l'oeuvre du milieu
qui a été aussi fourni jusqu'au jour de
sa disparition
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on